le projet de loi numéro 21 loi sur la
laïcité de l'état un projet de loi
dénoncé dès son dépôt les manifestations
et des appels à ne pas respecter la loi
je suis pour la désobéissance civile à
premier ministre canadien qui s'opposent
au premier ministre québécois c'est
impensable que la société libre
légitimise ray la discrimination comme
on dit on a déjà joué dans ce vieux
films là un air de déjà-vu pour michel
payet qui a travaillé pour le conseil
supérieur de la langue française pendant
une vingtaine d'années
ça a été des années le dépôt du projet
de loi 101 préparé par camille laurens
créé l'indignation à l'été 2009 177 la
presse anglophone le condamnent
unanimement le québec deviendra un
ghetto prédit un député le premier
ministre canadien
riposte la résistance s'organise
rapidement des commissaires scolaires et
d'une présidente syndicats invitent à la
désobéissance civile
l'assemblée nationale siège tout l'été
la loi est finalement adopté au terme de
200 heures de travaux parlementaires de
ceux des commissions scolaires de
montréal annoncent qu'elles continueront
d'accueillir tous les enfants même ceux
qui n'ont pas le droit à l'instruction
en anglais il y avait des enfants admis
clandestinement dans les écoles
anglaises tadjik chez jean faisait étape
à inscrire comme tel leur nom apparaît
chez aucune liste les comme change
colère je privais de la subvention
rattachés à ces élèves là le ministre de
l'éducation annonce qu'il restreindra le
financement des commissions scolaires
qui violent la loi mais la situation
perdurera pendant des années comme
l'illustrent ce reportage de l'époque
il faudra attendre le milieu des années
80 pour que la situation se résorbe
lorsque le gouvernement menace d'imposer
des sanctions plus sévères aux
récalcitrants est discutable
c'est une obligation de respecter la loi
c'est qu'à l'époque comme aujourd'hui de
nombreux outils sont à sa disposition
pour faire respecter la loi de la
demande d'injonction au pouvoir de
tutelle
ça peut être des pouvoirs de suspendre
des membres d'un conseil
d'administration par exemple ça
peut-être même au pouvoir de se
substituer à l'organisme administratif
qui ne ne respecte pas sa compétence le
premier ministre françois legault dit
vouloir adopter son projet de loi
rapidement pour mettre fin à un débat
qui dure depuis déjà plus de dix ans
l'expérience de la loi 101 nous laisse
entrevoir un autre avenir
une contestation difficile à apaiser et
qui se poursuit à la fois au sein de la
société civile est devant les tribunaux
ici hugo lavallée radio canada québec